en el vídeo anterior vimos un test de
hipótesis con dos colas cuando
analizamos el problema de la media de
respuestas de una rata a un determinado
estímulo cuando se le aplicaba cierto
medicamento
intenta hipótesis que vimos fue de dos
colas como les decía porque analizamos
la pregunta que decía si el medicamento
modificaba o no es decir preguntamos si
modifica
en la media de respuesta
media de respuesta
nosotros habíamos hecho el problema nos
planteaba un experimento un análisis con
100 ratas
las cuales mostraron una media de
respuesta mucho más baja luego de
aplicarles ciertos medicamentos nosotros
sabemos que la media de respuesta de las
ratas es de 12 segundos mientras que
luego de aplicarles el medicamento la
media de esta muestra nos dio 105 una
una media mucho más baja y luego nos
preguntamos si modifican la media de
respuesta este medicamento es decir no
si la modifica hacia abajo sino si la
modifica por ley por lo tanto y por eso
nosotros cuando analizamos las
cuestiones trabajamos con una
distribución muestral a dos colas una
teníamos en calma
trabajamos a dos colas una por sobre la
media y otra por debajo de la media o
del rango en verdad nosotros teníamos
también
tres desviaciones típicas
tres unidades nos corremos tres unidades
de desvío típico hasta llegar al punto
crítico que era en este caso 105 y en
este otro caso
35 teníamos estos dos valores porque nos
preguntábamos simplemente si se
modificaba la media de respuesta ahora
bien también existen los tests de
hipótesis de una sola cola y para
realizarlo con este mismo problema lo
que tendríamos que hacer es preguntarnos
si el medicamento
si el medicamento baja
el tiempo de respuesta
baja el tiempo de respuesta
entonces si preguntamos si nos
preguntamos si el medicamento baja el
tiempo de respuesta vamos a poder
realizar un test de hipótesis con
hipótesis distintas a las que teníamos
en el problema anterior en este caso
nuestra hipótesis nula va a seguir
siendo que el medicamento no modifica el
tiempo de respuesta decir que no hace
efecto es decir que sigue siendo 12
segundos aún con el medicamento
el medicamento
en cambio nuestra hipótesis alternativa
en este caso va a ser que moon es más
bajo o que el medicamento baja el tiempo
de respuesta es decir que es menor a 12
segundos
claro está con el medicamento verdad
y fíjense qué distinto es esto
de lo que podría ser y lo que fue en un
problema anterior a esto
este segundo caso nos obligaba a
analizar
lo que sucedía en las dos colas de
nuestra distribución muestral sin
embargo al analizar solamente el caso
menor a 12 estamos
no estamos sino que sólo con analizar lo
que sucede por debajo nos alcanza para
resolver la cuestión para resolver con
qué hipótesis nos quedamos
entonces como trabajamos con una muestra
una muestra
de 100 ratas
qué es una muestra haciendo es un número
importante por así decirlo trabajamos
con unas estadísticas con las llamadas
estadísticas z
de los valores z entonces nosotros
habíamos podido calcular que dada la
distribución muestral de las medias
muestrales
teníamos
en 1 a 12
muy bueno 12 teníamos que correr nos
tres unidades de desvío típico
y recién llegar en este punto
a la cola que nos interesa
luego de movernos tres unidades de
desvío típico en cuando lo analizamos
con dos colas también analizamos ésta
este área es decir calculábamos los dos
y habíamos llegado a la conclusión que
calculando las dos áreas
teníamos 03 % un número realmente bajo
pero como ahora no nos interesa esta
segunda cola sólo nos interesa los datos
menores
al valor buscado
escribir otra vez esto
vamos a decir que si las dos colas
simétricas es 0 3 % una sola es 0 3 %
o mejor dicho vamos a hacerlo
0 003
/ 2 esto es 0 0
0-15 es decir
0 15 %
y que no se está diciendo este 0 15 %
este 0 15% nos está diciendo que si no
rechazamos nuestra hipótesis nula
si las seguimos aceptando como
verdaderas a nuestra hipótesis nula
con el medicamento verdad todo es un
conjunto
tendríamos solo un 0 15% de
probabilidades de que ocurra lo que
ocurrió es decir de conseguir un
resultado más bajo
o igual a 0 a 10 5 segundos de respuesta
insisto
si no rechazamos la hipótesis nula vamos
a tener un 0 015 la probabilidad de
conseguir
conseguir un resultado
un resultado más bajo
105 segundos
si no rechazamos la hipótesis nula es
igual a 0 15% realmente un porcentaje
muy bajo por lo que con lo que sabemos
de tests de hipótesis decimos que
rechazamos
la hipótesis nula para asumir
la hipótesis alternativa como verdadera
cuando tenemos un porcentaje tan bajo
entonces decimos que rechazamos la
hipótesis nula
para asumir la hipótesis alternativa
como verdadera